seven rounds down only two to go in the
Grandmaster in international master norm
tournaments here in st. Louis at the
Chess Club Invitational today we had a
lot of drawers and a few players well
their games ended in heartbreak no
longer able to attend the norms they
came to st. Louis to earn I am nimir and
Sark are the only two in this section
still eligible to win their norms and
only one of them can make it caustic of
its key defeated the philippines angelo
young to keep his winning hopes alive
even though he can no longer norm yeah
so Angelo is a pretty tricky and
creative player I didn't really know
what he was going to do exactly so I
know he likes to play Kings Indian and
benoni type position so I'm mostly
prepared for that opening then when you
played e6 on move one that really
surprised me because I wasn't sure what
exactly he wanted I know he plays the
French defense but if I play Knight f3
and then you played b6 which allows me
to just play e4 immediately and white
gets a lot of space and I don't know if
white plays reasonably good moves I
think they get a good advantage so for
example here my opponent played e5 he
was trying to make this work Bishop a 6
she wants to trade these lights scored
bishops but I think after this move d5
white gets a really strong position and
this is the problem with not having a
lot of space is that once the position
opens up you know White's pieces become
much more active for instance if he
takes here I can take and now I'm
threatening something like d6 and
it's it's pretty difficult here already
for black so that's why he played d5 to
stop this when out your e five like it's
a lot of space and i found this pioneer
of be4 to put my pawn on b5 and his
strict his nine on v8 and then after
Queen 84 I found another good move here
night be one and the point is that the
night is coming to c3 and flagged us
something like castles here then after
Knight d2 this queen is going to get
trapped on a four after like 93 and 93
so if white just took this pawn on b3
black and play rook takes a four and
whites still better but black is pretty
much solid all their problems here
because they've traded some ponds so I
wanted to find a way to basically went
upon for white and keep my advantage so
I found the move here rugby one which is
pretty strong and the point is but I
can't take on a força c8 is hanging he
takes on c3 I'll take back with a night
and everything's defended and here's a
whole reason why this variation works is
because black also has back problems and
their pieces on d7 indeed are really
passive and get into trouble so if rook
takes c3 for example Knight takes rook
c8 it takes b3 Rick see for this seems
like the critical line I can simply play
here g3 giving my king a lift and but I
should probably take this pawn and then
85 and once i saw this i realized that
why it was probably going to win this
game point is that the pawn is starting
to run so black takes rook b7 the night
is hanging it whenever the night moves
why please rook v8 and wins the bishop
so because this doesn't work for black
they basically have to play down upon
and one swing
made a few more moves white on an extra
pawn and after 97 the game is basically
over no one is left to norm in the im's
but LaVon Bergonzi is the favorite there
are many hopefuls to win this tournament
including kabuki we'll see you tomorrow
at 11am at st. Louis chess club org for
the final showdown perhaps for the norm
when it comes to nemer versus Sarkar
you